je ne suis pas entré dans cette lutte pour
nommer le nombre de fois où j'ai été
arrêté je suis dans cette lutte pour
libérer l'ouganda
et avant que cela ne soit accompli je
me fiche du nombre de fois où je suis arrêté harcelé battu des
gaz lacrymogènes au papier  pulvérisé je garde les
yeux sur le
prix que vous essayez de politiser
[Musique]
des grenades ont été lancées et elles ont frappé ici car
vous pouvez voir
un autre coup ici
selon qu'ils ont
reçu des menaces de mort
des appels anonymes
m'avertissant de cesser de m'opposer à la suppression
de la limite d'âge
ou je serai tué
et brisé
euh
je veux toujours continuer l'appel
aux ougandais pour qu'ils défendent ce en quoi ils
croient je crois que c'est la chose la plus importante
à faire pour moi et je veux utiliser le
reste de ma vie pour
poursuivre ça
juste  comme il fut un temps où vous
n'êtes pas au pouvoir,
vous devez vous rappeler qu'il y aura un
moment où vous
n'êtes pas au pouvoir, vous devez donc traiter
les gens comme vous voulez être traité
au nom du peuple ougandais, je
vous défie  à une élection libre et juste
en 2021
oh
[Applaudissements]
et ces gens brutaux sont sur le point de
partir,
ils n'ont pas rendu compte des 35
ans qu'ils ont été au pouvoir
et maintenant tout ce qui leur reste est la honte de mère
innocente
eux,
nous vous l'avons déjà dit et nous continuons
à vous dire
qu'aucune brutalité, aucune quantité d'
autres,
aucune quantité de torture ou de pulvérisation de papier ne
va nous arrêter
littéralement, personne ne nous parle,
ils arrêtent juste des gens qui
battent des candidatures que
nous avons déjà  gagné, nous avons pu
réveiller massivement le peuple ougandais
si les gens étaient autorisés à sortir et à voter,
nous battrions Museveni avec plus de 80
%
parce que nous avons été dans toutes les régions de l'
ouganda et il est clair qu'il est évident
que le peuple ougandais  aspirent
au changement
[Musique]
vous